E aí
[Música]
o Imagine você viver uma vida
simplificada sustentável e livre e você
poder morar em qualquer lugar do Brasil
se sentir em casa aonde quer que você vá
mas como isso é possível nos dias de
hoje não é onde nós temos excesso de
informações cada vez mais cobranças e
vão combinar a gente mal tem tempo para
fazer aquilo que a gente realmente gosta
e no dia sete de maio de 2013 eu me vi
sem condições de sair de casa pela manhã
eu tive Pânico de enfrentar mais um dia
de trabalho aí foram três meses de
licença por síndrome de bournout em meio
a muitas lutas internas e outros
tratamentos o período passou eu achei
que tava recuperada e voltei a trabalhar
assumindo uma promoção depois eu indo
para o hospital com 31 anos de idade com
suspeita de infarto ou AVC Tava tendo
sintomas físicos e psicológicos fiz um
monte de exames e nada deu os médicos
lhe recomendaram e para o psiquiatra E
lá foi diagnosticado com síndrome de
bournout no meu caso o excesso de
trabalho e assédio moral eu estava
tirando a primeira licença de quatro a
síndrome de bournout ela é o estresse
extremo classificada como uma doença
ocupacional e hoje já
o 33 milhões de brasileiros infelizmente
ela é confundida com ansiedade e
depressão como uma forma de tratamento
nós somos afastados do trabalho e aí nós
começamos a refletir-se a vida que nós
tínhamos fazia mesmo no sentido à Vida
de trabalhar mais para consumir mais
para Se provar no meio social e acaba um
reflexo de tudo isso que além do stress
e de dívidas era uma péssima saúde e uma
baixa qualidade de vida também por
recomendação médica a gente começou a
prática de yoga e de meditação que nos
trouxeram autoconhecimento com isso veio
uma alimentação mais saudável a gente
começou a evitar o consumo de produtos
industrializados processados e de origem
animal nós conhecemos práticas de
conceitos de Lixo Zero e do consumo
consciente E aí através de um card touca
assim como esse fomos inspirados a
aderir
o mesmo como um estilo de vida e o
menino foi o nosso grande passo para a
mudança de vida que nós estamos propondo
para nossa basicamente nós fizemos um
exercício chamado pack Empire que é pra
foi proposto pelo minimalista né aqui
também não TED Talks né consistiu pegar
todas as coisas que você tem organizar
em caixas na Como se você tivesse
fazendo uma mudança né E você pega uma
caneta e Anota tudo classificando e
organizando obviamente todos os seus
pertences de tal forma que você consiga
acessá-los de maneira fácil né durante
um mês você vai retirar os objetos que
você precisa naquele momento né E você
terminou de utilizar se ele vai dormir
na caixa do governo você definir o local
ao final de um mês você vai lá e checar
Essas caixas O que você espera que vai
acontecer caixa vai tá cheio de coisas
que você utiliza ou seja sem utilização
somente em não foi surpresa para nossa
nós chegamos lá olhamos para cá
é cheia as caixas as caixas com vergonha
e é que você quiser mas só sei que usar
a regra básica do minimalismo tudo que
têm excesso você de fato elimina e foi o
que nós fizemos pegamos as coisas doamos
ou vendemos tudo aquele período que nós
estávamos morando numa casa de 167
metros quadrados de até porão quintal
digo lá né e com o minimalismo nós
estamos utilizando apenas cinquenta por
cento da casa então nós vendemos a casa
também é levar o celular dívida e a
nossa Âncora quem pedido a gente mudar
para esse estilo de vida que nós
estávamos procurando nessa época quando
a gente decidiu vender a casa e mudar de
vida nós fomos chamados de
irresponsáveis e inconsequentes Malucos
pela família pelos amigos pelos colegas
de trabalho não a gente tinha um filho
de 1 ano de idade e tava trocando
carreras ascendentes e uma vida estável
A Aventura por algo que era
completamente inusitado e desconhecido
mas o fato é que na época a gente tava
se sentindo mais Livres mais leves e
cada vez mais encorajados a fazer essa
mudança de vida e aí com todo esse
processo a gente foi ganhando muito mais
consciência sobre nós mesmos e sobre o
nosso impacto no planeta e aí a gente
foi em busca de um estilo de vida que o
Nice todos esses conceitos ou seja
conceitos de sustentabilidade conceitos
de minimalismo e conceitos de uma vida
livre simplificada e claro de
preferência que a gente tivesse uma casa
que fosse prática e que fosse funcional
aí nos conhecemos as time houses e nos
apaixonamos por ela a série houses elas
nasceram lá nos Estados Unidos no final
da década de 90 como um movimento
sócio-econômico mas ela só tiveram o seu
bumbum depois da crise financeira e
imobiliária de 2008
e elas ainda não tinham chegado aqui no
Brasil mas afinal o que são essas
winehouse's é o que o que palavra tá em
House bonitinha que Bel acabou de falar
Tree House São mini casas que são
construídas em até 37 metros quadrados
elas utilizam métodos de construção Seca
São funcionalmente sustentáveis porque
não utilizam agora a sua construção
podem ser construídas fixas ou móveis ou
seja Sobre Rodas aí que aí eu acho que o
sentimento porque eu vou escolhendo essa
casa porque família também mora lá no
Rio Grande do Sul a minha família mora
espalhadas por São Paulo e também tem
uma família lá no Rio Grande do Norte
Então abre a possibilidade a gente poder
levar essa casa que eu ia tudo isso que
simplificar os Avenida que era
sustentável e ainda poder levar sua casa
para qualquer lugar ou seja tem várias
experiências de vida né
o desenvolver sua casa não foi fácil não
foi fácil ligamos para várias empresas
né fomos procuramos parcerias
fabricantes eu vimos diversos não porque
nós não sabemos nem o que nós estamos
procurando sabe nem explicar direito o
que nós queremos né E quando você
Recebemos um sem venham carregados de
insegurança com o preço exorbitante
e talvez do Brasil não existe sua
empresa que nós estamos no procurado era
preciso fazer alguma coisa né
provavelmente não é foi a nossa primeira
grande dúvida o primeiro grande impasse
que a gente teve se a gente continuava a
frente com esse projeto ou se a gente
mudava o rumo mas a verdade é que a
gente tava apaixonada pelas time houses
a gente decidiu seguir em frente só que
nessa época a gente já tinha vendido a
casa já tava livre de dívidas E aí o
Robson se sentiu seguro de se desligar
da empresa que na época era nossa única
renda e aí a gente decidiu investir uma
viagem para os Estados Unidos que é o
berço da série houses e a nossa intenção
principal era Claro conhecer essas me
ligadas de perto mas vivenciar também
tudo isso aí a gente teve a oportunidade
de fazer cursos de projeto e de
construção nos conhecemos vários
fabricantes visitamos conhecemos
moradores e pessoas que construíram as
suas para
E também tivemos oportunidade de nos
hospedar em duas carinhosas uma delas
inclusive dentro de uma comunidade junto
com outra série House nesse período o
que aconteceu foi que a gente se deu
conta aqui não era só uma casinha
pequenininha mais uma casa que resgata o
convívio entre as pessoas entre os
moradores e entre a comunidade e uma
casa que nos conecta muito mais a
natureza alguma a gente sempre fala time
House é muito mais do que uma casa é na
verdade todo um estilo de vida né Agora
com toda sua experiência todo esse
conhecimento Nós voltamos para o Brasil
com um grande desafio né onde construir
como construir quanto iria custar e Como
legalizar
a primeira coisa nós fizemos foi fazer o
projeto 3D estamos ansiosas para ver
aquela casinha desenhada né Afinal ele
tinha bastante conhecimento de ácido já
feito treinamentos né desenhamos a casa
separamos ela em duas partes a base e a
casa obviamente né A base foi muito mais
fácil de você conseguir um fabricante
porque deu já tínhamos conhecido para os
fabricantes já tinha ligado para vários
deles agora já começo consciente pedimos
permissão brincarem enquanto esse cara
para você não fabricando eu somos atrás
os fabricantes da casa né ligaram para
vários etc em uma conversa com amigos
numa roda falando por mim não tô
conseguindo encontrar um cara para
brincar uma parceira ou uma empresa para
conseguir levantar essa casa e é um
amigo meu falou assim cara eu sei eu
trabalho com isso olha só um amigo
próximo e fazer muito tempo viviam né é
oferecer além de oferecer a sua
experiência né e o seu conhecimento numa
parceria para levantar essa casa né ou
seja com uma troca de conhecimento ao
vivo
o ensinando Aprenda uma nova profissão e
ofereceu o sítio para a para a gente
levantar essa casa e aí que começou esse
processo da construção da primeira these
houses do Brasil a gente saiu da capital
de São Paulo foi morar em um sítio no
meio do mato e junto com tudo isso
vieram Claro vários desafios vários
obstáculos porque a gente precisou
adaptar vários conceitos de construção
de treehouse lado de fora aqui para o
Brasil mas tudo foi aprendizado tudo foi
conhecimento adquirido a gente tava
afinal de contas construindo algo que
era inovador por aqui sem perceber a
gente tava na verdade era trazendo
movimento está em rosas aqui para o
Brasil são da nossa casa levou um ano e
três meses e a gente se mudou para ela
em agosto de 2019 diversas
transformações nossas vidas elas fez
cortei com consciência não sei não sei
se refletir sobre o
a cidade de espaço né o gente mora nessa
mina e casa pequenininha aqui com o
somente com essencial e a gente tá
satisfeita feliz não precisa de mais
nada nem disse nada ela tem 27 metros
quadrados a nossa Taine house mais claro
que você não precisa morar numa mina e
casa móvel para simplificar sua vida
você pode aderir a esses conceitos aí
mesmo onde você mora na sua casa
independente do tamanho dela o que a
gente quer comenda é que você comece a
aplicar hábitos conceitos do minimalismo
do time ele vem que você busque por
práticas que desenvolvam a sua
autocrítica e o seu auto conhecimento e
que você começa encorpora tudo isso no
seu dia a dia se você tá pensando que o
movimento está em House do qual a gente
fala é só sobre morar em Mira e casa
Sobre Rodas na verdade não é muito mais
do que isso
e ele é uma oportunidade para gente
conhecer o Real significado da Liberdade
Muito obrigado obrigado